We already know how to do the first part of this.
We just have to write a Boolean formula
for each single timestep.
The second part is also not that difficult.
If we are given an algorithm
and an input of that algorithm, we already know what the first snapshot
of the RAM is going to look like.
The program will start at the first line of the program code,
and the memory contains nothing but the input itself,
so given the way that the Boolean formula is written,
all we have to ensure that we enforce the variables
for the first snapshots
to represent that state that we already know,
but we can ensure that, so for example,
if in a Boolean formula, you want a variable x1 to be set to true,
you would write it like this; you would have certain statements of the Boolean formula,
and then you would just put the variable x1 here,
and then continue the formula,
and then you know it has to be set to true,
so in this way, you can enforce the
Boolean formula that represents the first snapshot
to present the memory of the RAM exactly at
time point t equals 0.
The fourth one here
that the Boolean formula can only be satisfied
if the algorithm returns yes;
that is also not that difficult to check,
because again using a technique like this here
all we have to do is ensure that at a certain point in time,
the algorithm here is at the program line
or the RAM executes the line of the algorithm here
or one line of the algorithm here
that says we return yes
so that algorithm gives us the yes value.
So the only part that requires a little more thought is the third part here,
how we can ensure that various snapshots fit together.